MORE TALKS WITH NORTH KOREA, AND
THEN SOME.
CHRIS.
>> Chris: THANK YOU, GREG.
NOW LET'S GET REACTION TO THE
SUMMIT FROM REPUBLICAN
SENATOR TOM COTTON OF ARKANSAS.
THE IRAQ WAR VETERAN IS A MEMBER
OF THE SENATE ARMED SERVICES'
COMMITTEE AND HE JOINS US FROM
CAPITOL HILL.
SENATOR, FROM THE VERY START YOU
HAVE BEEN IN YOUR OWN WORDS
DEEPLY SKEPTICAL OF
NORTH KOREA'S INTENTIONS.
NOW THAT IT'S OVER, WHAT YOU
THINK OF THE SUMMIT AND THE
AGREEMENT THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND KIM JONG UN SIGNED?
>> CHRIS, FIRST, THANKS FOR
HAVING ME ON TO DISCUSS THIS
INCREDIBLE DAY.
I THINK THIS WAS AN IMPORTANT
FIRST STEP BUT WE HAVE TO
REMEMBER IT WAS ONLY A FIRST
STEP.
I AM SKEPTICAL OF KIM JONG UN'S
COMMITMENT TO DENUCLEARIZING
NORTH KOREA.
I KNOW SECRETARY POMPEO HAS
ARTIE LEFT FOR SOUTH KOREA AND
THEN HE WILL BE IN CHINA
TOMORROW.
NOW IT'S TIME TO NEGOTIATE THE
NITTY-GRITTY DETAILS OF
VERIFIABLY AND IRREVERSIBLY THE
NUCLEAR RISING NORTH KOREA
PRESIDENT TRUMP HIMSELF SAID, IT
MAY NOT WORK OUT BUT THEY HAD TO
SIT DOWN AND HAVE DISAGREEMENT
FACE-TO-FACE BEFORE WE COULD
MOVE ONTO THE NEXT STAGE OF OUR
NEGOTIATIONS.
>> Chris: IN THE AGREEMENT,
KIM COMMITS TO "THE COMPLETE
DENUCLEARIZATION OF THE KOREAN
PENINSULA."
WE WILL HAVE TO WAIT AND SEE
WHAT HE DOES IN TERMS OF
NORTH KOREA, BUT ARE YOU
CONCERNED THAT HE IS DEMANDING
THAT ON OUR SIDE WE FOLD THE
NUCLEAR UMBRELLA WE HAVE HAD FOR
DECADES PROTECTING SOUTH KOREA
AND JAPAN.
>> NO, I'M NOT CONCERNED THAT
THE PRESIDENT WOULD WITHDRAW
THAT UMBRELLA FROM ANY OF OUR
ALLIES.
KIM JONG UN HOLDS THE ONLY
NUCLEAR WEAPONS THAT ARE ON THE
PENINSULA AND THAT IS ONE THING
THAT IS SUCH A THREAT NOT ONLY
TO SOUTH KOREA AND JAPAN AND THE
AMERICAN CITIZENS, BUT TO THE
UNITED STATES NOW THAT
KIM JONG UN HAS MISSILES THAT
CAN REACH THE UNITED STATES.
PART OF THE LONG-STANDING
AMERICAN POLICY IS THAT WE HAVE
A NUCLEAR ARSENAL PART TO
PROTECT OURSELVES AND OUR ALLIES
SO THEY DON'T FEEL THE NEED TO
OBTAIN NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
I FEAR THAT SOUTH KOREA AND
JAPAN AND TAIWAN WOULD WANT TO
OBTAIN NUCLEAR WEAPONS IF WE
WEREN'T WORKING TOWARDS THE
DENUCLEARIZATION OF NORTH KOREA.
>> Chris: THOUGHT, SENATOR, AS
PRESIDENT TRUMP ANNOUNCED THAT
HE IS GOING TO END JOINT U.S.
MILITARY EXERCISES WITH
SOUTH KOREA.
DO YOU THINK THAT'S A GOOD IDEA?
>> THE PRESIDENT SAID THEY WERE
PAUSING THEM FOR THE TIME BEING.
WE JUST HAD THE BIGGEST SINGLE
EXERCISE EACH YEAR OCCURS IN THE
SPRING THAT PROBABLY WON'T
HAPPEN FOR ANOTHER NINE OR TEN
MONTHS UNTIL THE SPRING OF 2019.
I THINK WE WILL HAVE A PRETTY
GOOD READ ON WHETHER KIM JONG UN
IS GOING TO KEEP HIS COMMITMENT
UNTIL THEN.
SAID HE WAS AWARE OF THE
SUSPENSION AND HE SUPPORTS THE
DECISION.
REGULAR, EVERYDAY TRAINING
EXERCISES WILL OCCUR.
SECRETARY MATTIS WOULDN'T HAVE
SUPPORTED THE DECISION IF YOU
WEREN'T CONFIDENT THAT OUR
TROOPS WOULD BE FULLY READY TO
DEFEND OUR INTEREST ON THE
KOREAN PENINSULA.
>> Chris: PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS
THAT HE MAY START EASING
SANCTIONS ON NORTH KOREA, EVEN
BEFORE IT ENDS ITS ENTIRE
NUCLEAR PROGRAM, COMPLETELY
DENUCLEARIZE, OFFERING THIS
EXPLANATION.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I THINK WE WILL DO IT AS FAST
AS IT CAN BE DONE
SCIENTIFICALLY.
AS FAST AS I CAN BE DONE
MECHANICALLY.
I DON'T THINK -- I MEAN, I'VE
READ HORROR STORIES, IT'S A 15
YEAR PROCESS.
ASSUMING YOU WANTED TO DO IT
QUICKLY, I DON'T BELIEVE THAT.
I THINK WHOEVER WROTE THAT IS
WRONG.
BUT THERE WILL BE A POINT AT
WHICH WHEN YOU ARE 20% THROUGH
YOU CAN'T GO BACK.
>> Chris: AS A MEMBER OF THE
SENATE ARMED SERVICES'
COMMITTEE, CAN YOU EXPLAIN WHAT
THAT MEANS WHEN YOU ARE 20%
THROUGH YOU CAN'T GO BACK?
>> I DON'T THINK THAT WE SHOULD
RELAX SANCTIONS IN ANY WAY UNTIL
WE ARE FAR DOWN THE PATH IF NOT
AT THE END OF THE ROAD OF
NORTH KOREA'S DENUCLEARIZATION.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT WAS USING
THAT NUMBER AS AN EXAMPLE.
HE WILL HAVE TO OPEN HIS COUNTRY
TO WEAPONS INSPECTORS.
HE WILL NEED TO MAKE A COMPLETE
DECLARATION OF HIS NUCLEAR
PROGRAM AND THEY WILL NEED TO
DEVELOP STEPS TO REMOVE THOSE
NUCLEAR MATERIALS AND CERTIFIED
AND DENUCLEARIZE.
THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT THAT ONCE
YOU GET FAR ENOUGH DOWN THAT
ROAD IT WOULD BE VERY HARD TO
REVERSE THOSE STEPS.
WE SHOULD NOT RELAX SANCTIONS UP
FRONT.
THAT'S ONE REASON WHY I WAS
OPPOSED TO DEAL WITH IRAN,
BECAUSE WE WERE RELAXING
SANCTIONS, GIVING CONCESSIONS ON
THE FRONT END FOR AN EASILY
REVERSED PROMISES AS OPPOSED TO
GETTING CONCRETE ACTION FROM OUR
ADVERSARY AND THEN TAKING ACTION
INTO THAT PROCESS.
>> Chris: IN THE MEANTIME, THE
PRESIDENT SAYS THAT HE IS GOING
TO MAINTAIN HIS SANCTIONS
REGIME, ALTHOUGH HE'S NOT GOING
TO CALL IT MAXIMUM PRESSURE
ANYMORE, BUT HE DID SAY THAT
SINCE THE NEGOTIATIONS HAD
STARTED, CHINA HAS EASED UP ON
SOME OF ITS TIGHT CONTROLS ON
ACTIVITY ACROSS THE BORDER.
IT SEEMS THAT SOUTH KOREA IS
ANXIOUS TO BEGIN TRADE WITH
NORTH KOREA AND THE QUESTION I
HAVE IS HAS BY NORMALIZING
THINGS, APPEARING HERE, MEETING
WITH PRESIDENT MOON OF
SOUTH KOREA, MEETING WITH CHINA,
AS KIM JONG UN ALREADY SUCCEEDED
TO SOME DEGREE IN WEAKENING THE
MAXIMUM PRESSURE CAMPAIGN?
NOT NECESSARILY BY THE
UNITED STATES, BUT BY THE REST
OF THE WORLD?
>> NO, I DON'T THINK HE HAS.
CHINA HAS ALWAYS DISPLAYED A
DOUBLE GAME WHEN IT COMES TO
NORTH KOREA ON THE ONE HAND
SAYING THEY WANT TO DENUCLEARIZE
NORTH KOREA BUT ON THE OTHER
HAND PROPPING UP THE REGIME
ECONOMICALLY, FINANCIALLY AND
POLITICALLY.
THEY REALLY ONLY CAME TO THE
TABLE OVER THE LAST 18 MONTHS
BECAUSE OF THE PRESIDENT'S
APPROACH SINCE LAST JANUARY.
THE SOUTH KOREAN ADMINISTRATION
THAT TOOK OFFICE EARLIER THIS
YEAR SIMPLY HAD A DIFFERENT
APPROACH THAN PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATIONS.
THE PRESIDENT HAS DONE A
GOOD JOB OF DEVELOPING A RAPPORT
WITH PRESIDENT MOON OF
SOUTH KOREA AND TRYING TO KEEP A
CLOSE ALLIANCE STRUCTURE BETWEEN
SOUTH KOREA, JAPAN AND THE
UNITED STATES TO ENSURE THAT
THAT PRESSURE CAMPAIGN
CONTINUES.
THE PRESIDENT MAY NOT WANT TO
SAY IT AFTER THE SUMMER, I WILL
SAY IT, WE NEED TO CONTINUE
MAXIMUM PRESSURE ON NORTH KOREA
UNTIL THEY DENUCLEARIZE.
>> Chris: FINALLY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD A NUMBER OF
VERY OPTIMISTIC THINGS TO SAY
ABOUT WHERE THINGS STAND NOW
WITH NORTH KOREA.
HERE ARE A FEW CLIPS.
>> IT'S A VERY GREAT DAY, IT'S A
VERY GREAT MOMENT IN THE HISTORY
OF THE WORLD.
I HAVE I THINK A VERY GOOD
RELATIONSHIP WITH CHAIRMAN KIM
RIGHT NOW.
I REALLY DO.
YOU CAN'T ENSURE ANYTHING.
ALL I CAN SAY IS THEY WANT TO
MAKE A DEAL.
>> Chris: SENATOR, DO YOU
SHARE PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
OPTIMISM?
>> WE SPLIT UP CERTAINLY BROKEN
OUT OF THE RUT OF 25 YEARS OF
FAILED U.S. POLICY TOWARDS
NORTH KOREA.
I DON'T KNOW IF KIM JONG UN IS
GOING TO KEEP HIS COMMITMENTS
WERE NOT THE PRESIDENT HAS SPENT
HOURS WITH HIM NOW AND VERY FEW
OF US HAVE THE BENEFIT OF THAT
EXPERIENCE.
I HOPE THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT.
BUT BECAUSE THE KIM REGIME, BOTH
KIM JONG UN AND HIS FATHER AND
HIS GRANDFATHER HAD A LONG
HISTORY OF DUPLICITY.
WE NEED TO CONTINUE OUR PRESSURE
CAMPAIGN, WE NEED TO HOLD
KIM JONG UN TO HIS COMMITMENTS.
I THINK WE WILL FIND OUT IN A
MATTER OF MONTHS WHETHER HE'S